Ubisoft got a battery on the way The
Last of Us part 2 is not gonna have
story DLC and Call of Duty warzone is
gonna have a 200 player mode I'm Kurt
Davina this is game spots news show save
state for Monday June 29th welcome I'm
sorry to inform you that the Last of Us
part 2 is not gonna have any additional
story content but instead the online
multiplayer mode is still on the way the
game's director Neil druckmann confirmed
I'm kind of funny saying quote no with
the Last of Us I think we had some
season pass or something that said ahead
of time we have some story DLC no
there's no plans for that with the last
of his part 2 and that's too bad because
I was really hoping for a feel-good
edition onto that game 1 we're le just
stays home reading comics and does like
Prince covers on our guitar but whatever
I'll keep dreaming of my own wholesome
version news aside the comment in that
game I personally love so seeing that
expand into an online mode similar to
the first one it gets me excited
Ubisoft has drop it into the battery
Alessandra that's right I went there and
it's with a game called hyper scape and
we're gonna be getting a look at it on
July 2nd according to East 4th reporter
rod Breslau it's an FPS battle royale
game set in a virtual world Breslau says
of various twitch streamers and
influencers were previously invited to
see the game ahead of the reveal in the
meantime there's already a site online
teasing lore around the game the website
focuses on a tech company called Prisma
dime mentions which is pitching grand
ideas like creating a hyper-connected
world with limitless opportunities so
from the looks of it it looks like
players are gonna plug into this thing
and fight each other that way which is
[ __ ] because that's like what we
actually already do whoa in an even more
trippy connection to reality looks like
the game is going to have a lot of
integration with twitch letting chat
influence what's happening in the game
like voting for speed or health boost
items and earn progress in their own
game just by watching hyper scape is
reportedly launching on PC and consoles
with cross play on July 12th more batter
all news Call of Duty warzone is adding
a 200 player mode
it's coming tonight in an update that
will launch at 11:00 p.m. Pacific normal
player count is 150 but there's a
limited time quads mode that will bump
that to 200 players new gear is also on
the way like a spotter scope which
according to its blog says quote this
reusable scope allows you to scan the
environment around you and mark enemies
without being detected
it's another beefy update at 22 to 30
gigs depending on the platform you have
so be aware of that consider that my
Call of Duty warzone PSA update PSA
they're big they're always huge so yeah
you should know this while you're here
don't forget GameSpot is doing play for
all a multi-week exciting big fun video
game events where every single day from
12:00 to 2:00 p.m. Pt we're raising
money for black lives matter and people
fighting on the front line for kovat 19
on these charity streams we are having a
bunch of special guests just last week
we had people from Red Dead Redemption 2
and Naomi Kyle on this Tuesday we have
what's good games joining us on
Wednesday we have Mary Kish on Thursday
we have super eyepatch wolf and then on
Friday we have people make games Chris
Brandt and then accompanying these
change teams we have a ton of exclusive
content so be on the lookout ok that's
it for today's news there's that and a
whole bunch more on gamespot.com so be
sure to check it out again I'm Kareem
Davina thanks for being here be well you
know the drill
just be cool be nice yeah ok
see you later
[Music]